[Music]
down
it's
[Music]
you mewing you around you me swing you
around see but you kept
stopping you stop right
there
around are you afraid to be off balance
[Music]
around
yes relax
[Music]
I'm not going to protect you
anymore you're going to come around your
momentum going that way
see you see which way is it going it's
going around so keep it going that's
it oh yes
[Music]
out
not good not one yet
oh
[Music]
your
hand you see come
here push on my shoulders
push you see good readying I'm going to
strike got it
push okay not like
okay down or this way lift your
hand you see hit you feeling power
right here
power
power lift
lift you see
Power you're going to do it slow
but it's got to be
right minute life right but I'm in the
right place slow but right
place so on this one don't make
him go around you with your your body
making a
circle you're eyes going
yielding you see and it starts the hour
that's
it so if you watch my hand it stays in
front of me my hips turn but if I unturn
my you see St in
front turn my
hi comes down towards
me straight
down can't go outside my shoulder
line boom right here in my Center boom
down
[Music]
me down
my down the
me my body my hips
turn but my arms
down my arms going here here here
here here here
[Music]
try just that TR without the TR St
cuz you have a hard time getting on top
of the
arm okay the first move is here do you
see how much I've turned stay there the
camera you see let me here okay cuz I'm
doing the inward
spiral so I do the inward spiral I'm not
here I'm over here and when I go
around CER say it's going to get on top
you see it's on top and now it's on the
outside you go here like this you're not
going to get there you're supposed to
been over
here you don't get there going cutting
down you feel his power so you go
around you do that first move
okay try
and then the the sh part is always the
same so you always
hear on the wrist with your C grip and
your pinkies cranking that thing down
okay you're never here you're never
here so you take that last drill and you
come around it's right there you can
sometimes I pass it to the other hand if
you pay attention
pass it to the
other
the but you have to get there you have
to get off the
forearm and you have to
get on the
wrist still without the
throw no throw there
Pinky
Okay this is a I she variation so we all
saw like how soed and low he is you see
he's ready to go flying when you go from
speed okay so I it doesn't make sense
he's going around me and I go like this
he's not going to be there you get it
it's more a combination he goes around
me and I go under him okay not me enter
turn and enter again he's gone by that
time so you're going to see how he's
going around me and I go under
him because of the tilt of his of of the
kazushi how he is
I can't really go that I got to go under
here
so I go
under so I'm not
dropping after I
Venter you see then I'm pulling I'm not
pulling him down he's already falling
down he's falling down like you saw all
the
okay so over Bo look
how Bo I
Dro so I'm not really pulling down on
him he's already falling
I'm going to displ you
turn body
turn you're going like
this this is conscious
Movement Center
lock boom you see turn as a
un see
now turn into unit
around turn
as
around unit
[Music]
you
see turn as a unit that's
[Music]
it don't disconnect
Right Center boom
it tension Let It Go Let It Go release
like the beginning